[Music]
if you've played more than 20 minutes of
outer wilds you probably recognize this
sound maybe you were in a mysterious
observatory maybe you were hurtling
through the endless cold of space or
maybe you were sitting by a campfire
calmly roasting marshmallows while your
friend played the banjo and then the Sun
exploded engulfing the solar system and
everything you've come to know such are
the stories of outer wilds released this
summer for PC and Xbox one mobius
digital's breakout hit combines the
lofty concepts of astrophysics with the
charm of a childhood camping trip it's a
game of frustrations and revelations
knowledge gained and time lost it wears
its inspirations on its sleeve but has a
distinct identity of its own in my
opinion it's one of the year's best
games and this week it released on ps4
and after catching up with two of outer
wilds creators to hear the story of how
it came to exist I was surprised to
learn it almost didn't seven years ago
teachers at USC's Interactive Media
master's course gave their students a
prompt create a video game that
demonstrates Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle basically the uncertainty
principle states that it's impossible to
measure the exact location and the exact
momentum of an object at the same time
imagine a photo of a car by definition
the photo captures the car at one moment
in space in time we know exactly where
the car is however because it's frozen
we can only guess as to its momentum so
we get the car moving and the problem is
seemingly solved but of course now we
can't pinpoint the car's exact location
anymore in my very basic non physicists
understanding this is the uncertainty
principle so a guy named Alex Beecham
along with his classmates began work on
this prompt the project included a log
cabin surrounded by trees that warped to
a new location each time you turned her
back on it it was a simple video game
embodiment of the uncertainty principle
and by extension quantum mechanics it
would also become the backbone of outer
wilds as we know it because working on
these prototypes peaked the team's
curiosity they became interested in
other scientific concepts as well
they dabbled in astrophysics they
explored the idea of nonlinear languages
they envisioned spaceships black holes
and geological anomalies the result was
a mash-up of minigames with no unifying
threat and that's when it hit them this
is no man sky was even announced and so
space exploration games sort of a dead
Shondra let's make a space exploration
game and let's make it kind of make it
feel more like an Apollo 13 or a 2001
then other space exploration games that
had already been made and so from the
beginning the idea was to make something
that was a very much about exploration
an exploration for the sake of curiosity
after graduating from USC Beechum joined
one of his former classmates at Mobius
digital with several group projects
already underway outer wilds took
somewhat of a backseat Beechum and his
colleagues had to work on it in their
spare time slowly fleshing out the idea
that began at USC this concept footage
shows outer wilds in one of those
earlier states as fate would have it
though years of free time led to a
pretty solid foundation in fact by 2015
mobius had an unfinished build of outer
wilds and with the independent Games
Festival looming they decided on a whim
to submit the game for consideration as
it happens it won both the excellence in
design category as well as the Seamus
McNally grand prize despite the team's
other ongoing projects they're showing
at IGF made it clear they really needed
to finish outer wilds and to do so they
would need more like-minded developers
specifically to refine the game's art
direction first this weird like thank
you looking student game that's winning
all these awards was kind of strange
and then like a couple weeks later I
happen to be looking for a job in LA or
yeah I heard about this position here
I guess I like didn't live the prototype
online and like give it a shot and then
it was 4:00 in the morning and I was
like trying to figure out you know how
to get it sooner that dark print ball
and at that point I was like cooked
already and it just sort of naturally
meshed with Who I am as a person I grew
up like in the coastal redwoods living
at my camp I love exploring nature and a
sci-fi concepts and space travel and all
of that and so like as soon as I
actually played the game and so it was
like I basically as a 3d artist Martin
brought a valuable perspective to the
studio in its earlier phases outer wilds
had a major problem
it was promising in a design sense but
it needed personality it was all heady
concepts and intellectual stimuli there
was very little for most players to
relate to that's where Martin came in
along with a newly formed art team he
helped to flesh out the games world with
conifer forests sweeping vistas and
natural rock formations this game about
space travel and quantum physics finally
had a human touch it became a game in
which you could not only watch the Sun
explode you could revel in the beauty of
it so with an emotional element attached
to their prototype mobius had a clearer
vision for the final product after a
successful crowdfunding campaign and a
partnership with Annapurna interactive
all that remained was just to finish the
game but of course game development is
no simple task and outer wilds is no
simple game not only does it play with
space travel in quantum mechanics but
also a concept that video games have
struggled with for decades time itself
partly just because like game worlds
tend to be super static and they don't
do a lot of really you know kind of
crazy interesting things and it's just
seemed like a fun place to explore and
you know you make an exploration game
the world is changing when becomes just
as important as where you need to play
you did get to explore it's time as well
as space and that seemed to mesh really
well and then
because we wanted to make a space
exploration game that was sort of
focused on the sense of real world space
exploration we wanted to make sure that
didn't feel like the world was revolving
around the player and so it was always
important that sort of where the
Majora's Max thing came in because
Majora's Mask does really awesome job
like the only Zelda gamer you don't feel
like everything is just like waiting for
you to do something and that was always
a really important aspect we didn't want
it to feel sort of like the world was
like the world could easily go on and so
originally there was actually a question
it was like okay is this gonna be more
like a roguelike where you knew run Zeus
and this format of the game was gonna be
like you're gonna prepare for each year
each adventure in space you're gonna
kind of like figure out like what type
of probe are you gonna bring like what
type of jetpack and it was gonna be like
okay you like assemble your gear and
then you have you go off into space at
some point you die good job like that's
your run that reset and there were gonna
be more proceed to the rule was gonna be
more procedural it's gonna be more of a
roguelike and the more we thought about
it and kind of worked on it it was just
sort of became clear that that wasn't
really the thing one to spend our time
on drawing from the Afro mentioned Zelda
title as well as comedy classic
Groundhog's Day Mobius settled on a more
elegant structure it's based on
20-minute loops after which the game
worlds Sun explodes engulfing you and
the entire solar system
you're then treated to a rapid replay of
your most recent adventure and then you
wake up and you do it all over again
of course each mini adventure is
different despite the solar system
resetting physically you and in turn the
playable character remember the secrets
you've earned instead of combat perks or
weapon upgrades persisting across
playthroughs outer wilds most valuable
asset is knowledge if most open-world
games are static
how would you in a nutshell describe the
world of outer Wow's never do that by
the way yeah we always joke that outer
worlds is the game you shouldn't try to
make just from like a from a building
the game perspective like we had we used
unity for our engine but like so much of
this stuff in unity it's designed to use
with static objects because that's just
like how you optimize things
in game engines and that's why every
game is like baked lighting all these
things and just from the ground level we
were like we're just not going to have
any static objects in the entire game
and that made it difficult to make heart
it made it difficult to be performant it
made it difficult to do lighting and fog
and like all these things that you kind
of take for her in it as like a game
artist what yeah you can just do this in
a game we just couldn't do those things
but it was like pulling teeth the entire
time to just do even just like simple
level design we were building on spheres
I think programs like Maya are built on
grid systems like you can't just model
things around the sphere easily and so
like I like sort of what your custom
modeling tools of my own so that we
could like extrude things and move them
around spherically yeah every step of
the way it was like okay how are we
going to do this normal game development
thing that everybody does but we can't
because everything's moving and changing
when outer wilds began development space
exploration games were a genre in exile
but as the years continued they
flourished we saw the release of Kerbal
space program elite dangerous and the
infamous juggernaut no man's sky by all
means it was a genre Renaissance and in
the grand scheme of things outer wilds
should have missed out but despite its
origins as a student project despite its
seven-year development cycle
despite the battles its creators had to
fight with the very tools they needed to
make it outer wilds released to
widespread critical acclaim it's now
playable on ps4 PC and Xbox one it even
earned a spot in the latter's coveted
game past program surprise definitely
cuz like at least when I joined the team
like I already played the Alpha built so
I was like I know there's magic here we
just need to not mess it up right and
the whole four years we were worried
about like messing it up we're like
we're gonna ruin it like there's no way
we can actually pull off this crazy
experimental game to the whole quality
that it needs to be at everybody who
like joins the team believe did that
version of the game and so it's really
inspiring and exciting to see people
playing the game
so believe in it the same way that we
did what we were making it people who
are like self-professed Call of Duty
fans and like very little else would
like come out of playtesting like I want
to go learn where about quantum
mechanics or just like do we pay you say
that I don't think we did you know he
was definitely yet towards the end we
were like okay no this is going to work
for at least a lot of people you never
bear to hope that it's gonna you know
have the kind of response that it's that
it's had